[Música]
[ERRADICACION DE LA POLIOMELITIS EN LAS AMERICAS]
[Narrador:] Poliomielitis, una enfermedad que ha afectado al ser humano desde los comienzos de la civilización.
Se conocía ya hace tres mil años, como podemos ver en este
jeroglífico egipcio que nos describe la aflicción de un sacerdote de la época.
Este mal es causado por un virus que afecta el sistema nervioso central,
produciendo frecuentemente parálisis, y en algunos casos la muerte.
Grandes epidemias de polio han causado incontables casos de parálisis, especialmente infantes a través de la historia.
El primer paso hacia su conquista fue realizado en el año 1908 por los investigadores Landsteiner y Popper.
En el año 1949 los científicos Enders, Robbins, y Weller descubrieron que,
por medio de cultivos humanos, el polio virus podía hacer propagado.
Pocos años después, en 1953 el doctor Jonas Salk informó que seres humanos podían
ser inmunizados en forma efectiva utilizando polio virus inactivado.
Posteriormente en 1962, el doctor Albert Sabin desarrolló una vacuna de polio virus vivo
que podía ser administrada oralmente contribuyendo en forma dramática a la reducción de este mal.
Actualmente hemos entrado a un nuevo periodo en la lucha contra esta enfermedad.
La meta esta vez es su completa eliminación del continente americano.
Con este motivo, el 14 de mayo del 1985 en la sede de la Organización Panamericana de la Salud
se reunieron agencias internacionales, representantes de gobiernos,
organizaciones de voluntarios, así como gran cantidad de individuos e instituciones relacionadas
con salud pública coordinando sus esfuerzos para erradicar poliomielitis entre ahora y 1990 de las Américas.
En esta ocasión el Dr. Carlyle Guerra de Macedo, director de la Organización Panamericana de la Salud anunció,
[Dr. Carlyle Guerra de Macedo:] Mi complace es extender más cordiales de las bienvenidas a los distinguidos científicos,
dirigentes políticos, y miembros de cuerpo diplomático que nos honran hoy
con su presencia en la Organización Panamericana de la Salud.
Y que, al comparecer en este acto, reafirmo una vez más el compromiso solidario contraído
para combatir a toda costa la enfermedad en las Américas.
En las Américas cada año hay una pérdida de 800,000 niños menores de un año
que mueren por causas que pueden prevenirse con los medicamentos y tecnologías relativamente comunes ya disponibles.
Entre estas tecnologías la inmunización es una de las más eficaces y eficientes.
Tenemos las vacunas para prevenir seis
enfermedades--el sarampión, la difteria, el tétanos, la tosferina, la tuberculosis, y la poliomielitis.
Hemos logrado extender la cubertura al 60% de los niños
de las Américas expuesto a riesgos de contraer estas enfermedades.
Y hemos logrado reducir el número de víctimas de poliomielitis.
Ha llegado la hora de que resolvamos acabar de una vez por todas
con la amenaza de esta enfermedad incapacitante que todavía se cierne sobre los niños de las Américas.
Mientras no se erradique polio virus el peligro de brotes repentinos de poliomielitis seguirá existiendo.
La única forma segura de proteger a nuestros niños contra espectro
de poliomielitis es la erradicación de virus de esta enfermedad de nuestro continente.
Con la ayuda de todos es factible interrumpir la transmisión autóctona del polio virus salvaje en el continente para 1990.
Creemos firmemente en que es posible reducir el número anual de casos a cero.
Y proponemos que sí preste a los gobiernos miembros de la Organización Panamericana de la Salud
todo el apoyo necesario para lograr erradicación de poliomielitis de las Américas
en esfuerzo conjunto masivo y final durante los próximos cinco años.
Ha llegado el momento de declarar que es inaceptable que cualquier niño de las Américas sufra de poliomielitis.
[Aplausos]
[ORGANIZACION PANAMERICANA DE LA SALUD -1985-]